the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so my name is Michael Peron and I'm at
the TJ Watson Research Center IBM
Research doing all kinds of things for
research but most recently no that's not
what I want know most recently I've been
working with the sale processor for the
past three years or so how's that and
because I do have to run out for a
flight I have my email here if you want
to ask me questions feel free to do that
what I'm gonna do in this presentation
is as someone suggested talk in depth
about the sale processor but really it's
still going to be just the very surface
because you're gonna have a month to go
into a lot more detail but I want to
give you a sense for why it was created
the way it was created what it's capable
of doing and what are the programming
considerations that have to be taken
into mine in mind when you program
here's the agenda just for this section
like of this class give you some
motivation this is gonna be a bit of a
repeat so I'll go through it fairly
quickly talk about the design concepts
Hardware overview performance
characteristics application infinity
what what good is this device talk about
the software and this I imagine is one
of the areas where you're going to go
into a lot of detail in next month
because as you suggested the software
really is the issue and and I would
actually go a little further I'd say you
know why do people drive such large cars
in the u.s. why do they waste so much
energy the answer is very simple it's
because it's cheap even at $3 a gallon
it's cheap compared to say Europe and
other places and the truth is it's the
same thing with programmers why did
programmers programmer the way they did
in the past 10 20 years because cycles
were cheap
they knew Moore's law was gonna keep
going and so you could implement some
algorithm we didn't have to worry about
the details as long as you got the right
you know power law if you got your N
squared or and cubed or log n log and
whatever behavior the details if it was
you know the multiplying factor was ten
or a hundred didn't matter eventually
Moore's law would solve that problem for
you so we didn't have to be efficient
and I think I've spent the better part
of three years trying to fight against
that and you even learn in this class
that particularly for multi-core you
have to think very hard about how you're
going to get performance this is
actually the take-home message that I
want to give it I think it's just one or
two slides but we really need to get to
these because that's where I want to get
you thinking along the right lines and
then there's a hardware consideration we
can skip that all right so where of all
the gigahertz gone right we we saw
Moore's law things getting faster and
faster and the answer is I have a
different chart it's basically the same
thing you have relative device
performance on this axis and you've got
a year here and different technologies
were growing growing growing but now you
see their threshold and you go to
conferences now architecture class
conferences and people are saying you
know Moore's law
dead now I don't know if I would go that
far and I know there are true believers
out there who say well maybe the silicon
nontox insulator technology is dead but
there'll be something else and maybe
that's true and maybe that is multi-core
but unless we get the right programming
models in place
it's not gonna be multi-core there's
this power density graph here we have
the nuclear reactor power up here and
you see Pentiums going up now of course
there's a log plot so we're far away but
not on this axis we're not far away this
is how much we shrink the technology the
size of those transistors right so if
we're kind of going down by 8 by 2 every
18 months or so maybe it's 2 years now
we're not so far away from that nuclear
reactor output and that's a problem
and what's really causing that problem
here's a picture of one of these gates
magnified a lot and here's a the
interface magnified even further and you
see here this dielectric that's
insulating between the two sides of the
gate we're reaching a fundamental limits
a few atomic layers you see here it's
like 11 angstroms what's that
10 11 atoms across if you go back to
your basic physics you know that you
know quantum mechanical properties like
like electrons third a tunnel right and
they tunnel through barriers with kind
of an exponential decay so whenever you
shrink this further you get more and
more leakage so the current is leaking
through in this graph what you see here
is that as the size gets smaller the
leakage current is getting equivalent to
the active power so even when it's not
doing anything under this 65 nanometers
the technology is is leaking as much
powers actually uses so and eventually
as we get smaller smaller we're gonna be
using more power just leaking stuff away
and that's really bad because as someone
suggested we have people who are like
google putting their stuff near the
Coulee Dam so that they can get power I
deal with a lot of customers who have
tens of thousands of nodes 50 thousand
processors 100 thousand processors
they're using 20 gigabytes sorry
megahertz no one right megawatts that's
what I want to say it's too early in the
morning is it tens of megawatts to power
their installations and they're choosing
sites specifically to get that power and
they're limited and so they come to me
they come to people at IBM and said what
can we do about power power is a problem
and that's why we're not seeing
increasing megiddo Hertz has this ever
happened before well I'm gonna go
through this quickly yes here we see the
power outage of output of a steam iron
right there per unit area oops and
something's messed up here Wow
you see this the technology changed from
bipolar to CMOS we were able to improve
the performance but the heat flux get
higher again and it begs the question
what's gonna happen next and of course
IBM Intel AMD they're all betting this
multi-core and so there's an opportunity
from a business point of view so now
that's the intro multi-core how do you
deal with it here's a picture of the
chip the Cell processor you can see
these eight little black dots they're
local memory for each one of eight
special purpose processors as well as a
big chunk over here which is a ninth
processor so this chip has nine
processors on board and trick is to
design it so that it addresses lots of
issues that we just discussed so let me
put this in context cell was created for
the Sony Playstation 3
it started in about 2000 and you know
there's a long development here until it
was finally announced over here
where was it first announced it was
announced several years later and IBM
recently announced a cell blade about a
year back and we're pushing these blades
and we're very much struggling with the
programming model how do you get
performance while making something
programmable you go to customers and
they have 4 million
lines of code you can't tell them just
port it and you know it'll you know
it'll be twenty eighty person years to
get it ported a hundred person here's
more and then there's you have to
optimize it it's all their problems and
we'll talk about that but there was it
was created in this context and because
of that it's this this chip in
particular is a commodity processor
meaning that it's gonna be selling
millions and millions Sony Playstation 2
sold an average of twenty million units
each year for five years and we expect
the same for the PlayStation 3 so the
the the cell has a big advantage over
other multi-core processors like the
Intel Woodcrest which has a street price
of about two thousand dollars and the
cell is you know around a hundred so not
only do we have big performance
improvements we have price advantages
too because of that commodity process
market alright so let's talk about the
design concept here is a little bit of a
rehash of what we discussed with some
some interesting words here we're
talking about a power wall a memory wall
in frequency wall so we've talked about
this frequency wall we're hitting this
wall because of the power really and the
power wall people just don't have enough
power coming into their buildings to
keep these things going but memory wall
someone didn't actually use that term
but that's the fact that as the clock
frequencies get higher and higher memory
appeared further and further away
they're more cycles that I had to go as
a processor before the data came in and
so that changes the whole paradigm how
you have to think about it right we have
processors with lots of cash right but
it's cash really what you want well it
depends if you have a very localized
process where you're gonna bring
something into cash and the data is
gonna be reused then that's really a
good thing to do but what if you have
random gather and scatter of data you
know you're doing some transactional
processing or your your whatever
mathematical function you're calculating
is very distributed like an FFT right so
you have to do all sorts of accesses
through memory and it doesn't fit in
that cache well then
you're gonna start thrashing cash you
bring in one integer and then you ask
the cash for the next thing it's not
there so it has to go in and so you
spend all this time wasting time getting
stuff into cash
so what we're pushing for multi-core
especially for cell is the notion of a
shopping list and this is where
programmability comes in and programming
models come in you really need to think
ahead of ahead of time about what your
shopping list is going to be and the
analogy that people have been using is
you know you're fixing something in your
house your pipe breaks so you go into oh
I need a new pipe so you go the store
you get a pipe you bring it back and say
oh I need some putty so you go to the
store you get some putty and then oh I
need a wrench go story that's what cash
is right so you figure out what you need
when you need it and the Cell processor
you have to think ahead and make a
shopping list gee if I'm gonna do this
calculation I need all these things I'm
gonna bring them all in I'm gonna start
calculating when I'm calculating on that
I'm gonna get my other shopping list so
that I can have some concurrency of the
data load with the computes okay and
this is I'm going to skip this here
you can read that later it's not that
important okay self's energy now this is
kind of you know apple pie motherhood
kind of thing the Cell processor was
specifically designed so that those nine
cores are synergistic right that they
interoperate very efficiently now I told
you we have eight identical processors
we call those SPE s in the ninth
processor is a PPE we've it's been
designed so that the PPE is running the
OS and it's doing all the transaction
with file systems and whatnot so that
these SPE s can focus on what they're
good at which is compute the whole thing
is pulled together within element
interconnect bus and we'll talk about
that it's very very very efficient very
high bandwidth bus ok now we're going to
talk about the detail hardware
components and Roderick somewhere there
you are ask me to actually dig down into
more of the hardware I would love to do
that honestly I'm not a hardware person
and I can do is bet you know I'll do is
the best I can perhaps at the end of the
talk will dig down show me which slides
you want but I've been dealing with this
for so long that I can do it decent job
here's another picture of the chip it
has lots of transistors this is the size
we've talked about the nine cores and
has 10 threads because this power
processor the PPE has two threads each
of these are single threaded and this is
the wow factor we have 200 gigaflops
over 200 gigaflops of single precision
performance on these chips and over 20
gigaflops of double precision and that
will be going up to 100 Giga flops by
the end of this year the bandwidth to
main memory is 25 gigabytes per second
and up to 75 gigabytes per second of Io
bandwidth now this chip really has
tremendous bandwidth but what we've seen
so far particularly with the Sony
Playstation and I think you may have
lots of them here the the board is not
designed to really take advantage of
that bandwidth and even the blades that
IBM sells
really can't get that type of bandwidth
off the blade and so if you're keeping
everything local on the blade or on the
PlayStation 3 then you have lots of
bandwidth internally but off blade or
off board you really have to survive
with something like a gigabyte to
gigabytes in the future in this element
interconnect bus that I mentioned before
has a tremendous bandwidth 300 over 300
gigabytes per second of you the top
frequency in the lab was over 4
gigabytes a gigahertz sorry and it's
currently running when you buy them at
3.2 gigahertz and actually the
PlayStation 3s that you're buying today
I think they only use 7 out of the 8 SPE
s and that was a design consideration
from the hardware point of view because
you know as these chips get bigger and
bigger which is you know if you can't
ratchet up the gigahertz you have to
spread out and so as they get bigger
flaws in the manufacturing process lead
to faulty units so instead of just
throwing away things if one of these SPE
is bad we don't use it and we just do
seven as the design process gets better
by the end of this year they'll be using
8 the blades that IBM sells they're all
set up for 8 ok so here's a schematic
view of what you just saw on the
previous slide you have these 8 SPE s if
the PPE here with this l1 and l2 cache
and the element interconnect bus
connecting all of these pieces together
to a memory interface controller and a
bus interface controller and so this Mik
is what has the twenty five point six
gigabytes per second and this bik has
potentially 75 going out here each of
these SPE s has its own local store
those are those little black dots that
you saw those eight black dots
that's not very large it's a quarter of
a megabyte but it's very fast to this
sxu of this processing unit it's only
six cycles away from that unit and it's
a fully pipeline six so that you can
if you if you feed that pipeline you can
get data every cycle and here the thing
that you can't read because it's
probably too dark is a DMA engine so one
of the interesting things about this is
that each one of these is a fully a
full-fledged processor it can access
main memory independent of this PPE so
you can have nine processes or ten if
you're running two threads here all
going simultaneously all independent of
one another and that allows for
tremendous amount of flexibility in the
types of algorithms you can implement
and because of this bus here you can see
it's 96 bytes per cycle and we're at 3.2
gigahertz
I think that's 288 gigabytes per second
these guys can communicate to one
another across this bus bus without ever
going out to main memory and so they can
get much faster access to their local
memories so if you're doing lots of
computes internally here you can scream
on this processor you really really go
fast and you can do the same if you're
going out to the memory interface
controller here to main memory
if you sufficiently hide that memory
access so we'll talk about that all
right this is the PPE that I mentioned
before it's based on the IBM power
family of processors
it's a watered down version to reduce
the power consumption so it doesn't have
the horsepower that you see in say a
Pentium 4 or even a penny but I actually
I don't have an exact comparison point
for this processor but if you take the
code that runs today on your Intel or
AMD whatever your power and you
recompile it on cell it will run today
maybe you have to change a library or
two but it'll run today here no problem
but it'll be about you know 60% slower
50% slower and so people say oh my god
this cell processor is terrible well why
don't you do something buddy but that's
because you're only using that one piece
so let's look at the other people ok so
now we're going to the details of the
PPE half the gigabyte half a megabyte of
l2 cache
coherent load stores it does have a vmx
unit so you can do some simulations a
single instruction multiple data
instructions to a hardware
multi-threading pair then this is an e
ib that goes around here you can have
it's composed of four sixteen by data
rings and you can have multiple
simultaneous transfers per ring for a
total of over a hundred outstanding
requests simultaneously but but this
slide doesn't this kind of hides it on
the right there's a certain topology
here and so these things are going to be
connected to those eight SPE s and
depending on which way you send things
you'll have better or worse performance
so some of these buses are going around
this way and some are going
counterclockwise and because of that you
have to know who you're communicating if
you want to have real high efficiency I
haven't seen personally cases where it
made a really big difference but I do
know that there are some people who
found you know if I'm going from here to
here I want to put it I want to make
sure I'm sending things the right way
because of the that connectivity right
or else I could be sending things all
the way around and waiting okay so yes
the process will be slower would you
care but you also said the subprocessors
C code would compile there's issues with
libraries because the libraries wouldn't
be ported to the SPE necessarily if it
had been then yes this is this is
actually a very good question it opens
up lots of things I don't know if I
should take that later bottom line is
this product this chip has two different
processors and therefore you need two
different compilers and it generates two
different source codes and the in
principle SPE s can run a full OS but
they're not designed to do that and no
one is there
actually tried so you could imagine
having eight or nine OS is running on
this processor if you want it it's
terrible waste from my perspective but
okay so let's talk about these a little
bit
each of these SP es has like I mentioned
this memory flow controller here
anatomic update unit the local store and
the SPU which is actually the processing
unit the each SPU has a register file
with 128 registers each register is 128
bits so they're Native Cindy there's
there are no scalar registers here that
for the user to play with if you want to
do scaler ops they'll be running in
those full vector registers but it would
just be wasting some portion of that
register it has I Triple E double
precision floating point but it doesn't
have I Triple E don't pursue a single
precision floating point it's a
curiosity but that was again came from
the history the processor was designed
for gaming in industry and the gamers
they didn't care anyone I Triple E who
cares I Triple E what I want is to have
good monsters right on the screen and so
those those sim D registers can operate
bitwise on bytes on shorts on four words
at a time or two doubles at a time and
oh yeah the DMA engines here each diem a
DMA engine can have up to sixteen
outstanding requests in its queue before
it stalls so you can imagine you're
writing something some code and you're
sending things out to the DMA and then
all of a sudden you see really bad
performance it could be that your dma
engine has stalled the entire processor
if you try to write to that thing and
then that queue is full it just waits
until the next open slots available so
those are kind of either incinerations
yes
right that's correct that there's no but
there is a global address space 16 slugs
each kind of in each X being right
exactly each each s MFC has its own 16
slots and they all address the same
memory they can have a transparent
memory space where they can have a you
know a partitioned memory space to it
depending on how you set it up
data in our the SPU's - you don't have
to always go to outside memory you can
you can do Espie Espie you communication
basic right so I can do a DMA that
transfers memory from this local store
to this one if I wanted to in vice versa
and I can pull stuff in through the
let's see yeah I mentioned this stuff
okay so now this is this broadband
interface controller the BIC this is how
you get off the blade or off the board
it has 20 gigabytes per second here on
Io I F intend over here I'm sorry five
over here I'm trying to remember how we
get up to 70 this is actually two way in
one is 25 and the other ones 30 and I
get you the 55 and this should be 10 in
now what's going on here it adds up to
75 I'm sure I'm sure about this I don't
know why that says that but the
interesting thing about this over here
this iof 0 is that you can use it to
combine to connect two cell processors
together so this is why I know it's
really 25.6 because it's matched to this
one so you have 25.6 going out to main
memory but this one can go up to another
processor so now you have these two
processors side-by-side connected at
25.6 gigabytes per second and now I can
do a memory access through here to the
memory that's on this processor and vice
versa
however if I'm going straight out to my
memory it's gonna be faster than if I go
out to this memory so you have a slight
anula architecture and non-uniform
memory access and you can hide that with
sufficient you know but multi buffering
so I know that this is 25 and I know the
other ones 30 I don't know why it's
written as 220 there
yes they can they can read from it I
don't know think a right to it
in fact that leads to a bottleneck right
so I happily start a process on my PPE
and then I tell all my SPE start doing
some number crunching so they do that
they gak test the memory but they find
the memories in low l2 so they start
pulling for male 2 but now all 8 are
pulling from l2 and it's only 7
gigabytes per second instead of 25 and
so you get a bottleneck and so what I
tell everybody is if you're gonna
initialize data with that PPE make sure
you flush your cache before you start
the the SPD's and then you don't want to
be touching that memory with because you
you really want to keep things stuff
that the SPE s are dealing with you want
to keep it out of l2 cache there's an
interrupt controller and i/o bus master
translation unit and you know these
allow for messaging and message passing
and interrupts and things of that nature
okay so that's the hardware overview any
questions for anyone
so why is the sale process so fast so
fast well you know 3.2 gigahertz that's
one but there's also the knack that we
have eight SPE s HS 8 SPE s have Cindy
units registers that are running so they
can do this parallel processing on a
chip we have 8 SPE s and each one are
doing up to 8 cycle 8 ops per cycle if
you're doing a mole at so you have
formal ads for a single precision so
you've got 8 that's 64 ops per cycle
times 3.2 you get up to 200 gigaflops
per cycle 200 4.8 so that's that's
really the main reason but also there's
this we've talked about this stuff here
this is an image of why it's faster
instead of staging and bringing the data
through the l2 which is kind of what we
were just discussing and having the this
PU that's processing unity the PPE
managed the data coming in each one can
do it themselves and bypass this
bottleneck so that's something you have
to think keep in the back of your mind
when you're programming you really want
to make sure that you get this you this
processor out of there you don't want it
in your way let these guys do as much of
their own work as they can here's a
comparison of theoretical peak
performance of cell versus you know free
scale AMD Intel over here very nice
that's the wild chart that's the
theoretical peak this is in practice
what do we see I don't know if you can
read these numbers but what you really
want to focus on is the first and last
columns this is the type of calculation
high-performance computing like matrix
matrix multiplication
bioinformatics graphics security was
really designed for graphics right
security communication video processing
and over here you see the advantage
against you know an ia32 a g5 processor
and you see a X 12 X 15 10 to 18 X very
considerable improvements in performance
in the back question
all right so you're thinking like a peak
stream or something like that so I
believe and I'm not well-versed in all
of the processors that are out there I
think that we still have a performance
advantage in that space you know I don't
know about Xilinx and those kind of
things very FPGAs I don't know but what
I tell people is there's a spectrum and
at one end you have your general-purpose
processors you've got your Intel
you've got your Opteron whatever your
power processor and then at the other
end you've got your FPGAs and DSPs and
then maybe over here you've got your
somewhere in the middle you've got
graphical processing units right like
Nvidia kind of things and then somewhere
between those graphics processing
processors and the general-purpose
process you've got cell so it's you you
you get a significant improvement
performance but you have to pay some
pain and programming but not nearly as
much as you have to do with the graphics
processing and nowhere near the FPGAs
which are just you know every time you
write something at the rewrite
everything
yeah so this is actually one of the
things I spent a lot of time on for FFTs
I spent a lot of time with the petroleum
industry right they they take these
enormous boats they have these arrays
that go five kilometers back in one
kilometer why they drag them over the
ocean and they make these noises and
they record the the echo and they have
to do this enormous FFT and it takes
some six months it may can depending on
the size of the FFT it can be anywhere
from a week to six months literally
sometimes I do too
but they do both and it's I've become
somewhat of an expert on these in
fifties for sell the best performance
number I know of is about ninety
gigaflops of FFT performance and the you
know that's very good it's like 50% of
peak performance you know it's easy to
get 98% with Lyn with Lyn Packer or a
DGM on the processor like this and we
have we get it I don't know we get 97%
of peak performance but it's a lot
harder to get FFTs up right so you do a
lot of tricks I can show you another
slide where another presentation that we
talked about this but typically the FFTs
that we work with are somewhere from
1010 24 to 2048 that's square and so
it's possible to take say the top four
rows in in in the case of 1024 four rows
complex single precision I think is 16
kilobytes and so that fits into local
store very nicely so you can start multi
buffering you bring in one you start
computing on it while you're computing
on those four in a sim D fashion across
the sim D registers you're bringing in
the next one and then when that one's
finished you're writing that one out
while you're computing on the one that
arrived and while you're getting the
next one and since you can get the
entire you know 1024 or 2002 local store
you're only six cycles away from any of
the any element
so it's much much faster we also did a
16 million element FFT where 1d yeah and
we did some tricks there to make it
efficient but it was a lot slower I when
I remember it was a 15 times faster than
a power of five yeah I I could be it
might've been a power 4 I don't remember
sorry okay do I want to I might want to
skip this one I think I'm gonna skip
this one right okay so let's talk about
what is the cell good for you you kind
of have a sense of how the architecture
how it all fits together you may have
some sense for the gotchas and the
problems that might be there but what if
we actually applied it to I mean you saw
some of that here here's a list of
things that either we've already proven
to ourself that it works well or we're
very confident that it works well or
we're working to demonstrate that it
works well signal processing image
processing audio resampling noise
generation I mean you can read through
this list is a long list and I guess
there are a few characteristics that
that really make it suitable for cell
things that are in single precision
because we've got 200 gigaflops a single
in only 20 of double but that will
change as I mentioned things that are
streaming streaming through and so
signal processing is ideal where the
data comes through and you do your
compute and then you throw it away or
you give out your result and you can't
throw it away those are good and things
that are compute intensive where you
bring the data in and you're gonna
crunch on it for a long time so things
like cryptography where you're either
generating something from a key
and you know there's virtually no input
right you're just you're just generating
lost reams of random numbers that that's
very well-suited for this thing you see
FFT is listed here
tcp/ip offload I didn't put that there
put that there there's actually a
problem with cell today that we're
working to fix that the tcp/ip performs
is not very good and so what I tell
people to use is open MPI or you know so
that over InfiniBand the PPE processor
really doesn't have the horsepower to
drive a full tcp/ip stack I'm not sure
it has the horsepower to do a full MPI
stack either but at least you have more
control in that case okay the game
physics and physical simulations I can
show you a demo but I don't know that
we'll have time we're a company called
rapid mind which is developing software
to ease programmability for cell
basically you take your existing scalar
code and your instrument it with C++
classes that are kind of SPE aware and
by doing that just write your scalar
code and you get the SPE performance
advantage they have this wonderful demo
of these chickens they've got 16,000
chickens in a chicken yard and you know
the chicken yards kind of has varying
topologies and the chickens move around
and all 16,000 are being processed in
real time with a single cell processor
in fact the Nvidia card that was used to
render that couldn't keep up with what
was coming out of the SPE s so that we
were impressed with that we're happy
that we showed it around at the game
conferences and you know the gamers were
really there are all these chickens you
know how this is really cool how do I
shoot them and so we said all you can't
but maybe in the next version but the
idea that we've designed this so that it
can do physical simulations and this is
maybe an entree for some of you people
when you're doing your stuff I don't
know what kinds of things you want to
try to do on sale but I've seen people
do lots of things that really have no
business doing well on sell and they did
very very well like pointer chasing
right so you want to was trying to
remember there are two pieces of work
one done it by pnnl Fabrizio Petrini and
he he did a graph traversal algorithm
and you knows very much random access
and he was able to paralyze that very
nicely on cell and then there was
another guy at Georgia Tech who did
something similar for linked lists and
you know I expect things to work well on
cell if they're streaming and they have
very compute intensive kernels that are
working on these things but those are
two examples where they're very I'm not
very compute intensive and not very
streaming they're kind of random access
and they work very well
over here target applications there are
lots of areas where we're trying to push
self forward clearly it works in the
gaming industry but where else can it
work so medical imaging there's a lot of
success there the seismic imaging for
petroleum aerospace and defense for
radar and sonar these are all kind of
signal processing apps we're also
looking at digital content creation for
computer animation very well-suited for
cell this is kind of a just what I just
said
did I leave out anything finance once we
have double precision we'll be doing
things with finance we actually
demonstrated that things work very well
you know mantra metropolis algorithm is
Monte Carlo black Scholes an algorithms
if you're familiar with these kind of
things for finance and they tell us they
need double precision and we're like you
don't really need double precision come
on I mean you you what you have is you
know some some mathematical calculation
that you're doing and you're doing it
over and over and over and Monte Carlo
there's so much noise we saved these
people why do you need double position
turns out you know in with decimal
notation you can only go up to like a
billion right or something in a single
precision so they have more dollars than
that so they need double for that reason
alone but this gets back to the
sloppiness of programmers right and I'm
guilty of
myself they said oh we have double let's
use double they didn't need to but they
did it anyway and now they're good
legacy code is stuck with double they
could convert it all to single but it's
too painful down on Wall Street to build
a new data center it's like a hundred
million dollar proposition and they do
it regularly all of the banks they'll
they'll be generating a new data center
every year sometimes multiple times a
year and they just don't have time or
the resources to go through and redo all
their code to make it run on something
like sell so we're making double
precision sale that's the short of it
all right now software environment this
is the stuff that you could find on the
web and actually it's changing a lot
lately because we just released the 2.0
SDK and so the stuff that's in the
slides might not actually be the latest
and greatest but it's gonna be you know
epsilon away and so don't worry about it
too much
but you really shouldn't trust these
slides you should go to the website in
the website you want to go to is WWI BM
calm slash alpha Works recitation
session talking about the environment
that we have created I think I think we
just got probably just set up the latest
environment and really sit through the
three weeks because this is changing
faster than three weeks cycles be
something you tell you then int I think
about in around ten and so so this will
give you a preview of what's going to be
so alpha works then you go to Alpha X go
search on Alf works for cell and you get
more information than you could ever
possibly read we have a programmers
manual that's you know nine hundred
pages long it's really good reading
there actually there's one thing in that
eight hundred nine hundred pages that
you really should read it's called the
cell programming tips a chapter it's a
really nice chapter but there are many
many publications and things like that
more than just the SDK and in the OS and
whatnot so I encourage you look at that
all right
so this is kind of the pyramid this sell
software pyramid we've got the stay
under here the application binary
interface language extensions and over
here we have development tools and we'll
talk about each of these pieces briefly
these specifications define what's
actually the the reference
implementation for the cell C++ and C
they have language extensions in the
similar way to the extensions for vmx
and for SSE on Intel you have C
extensions for sale that allow you to
use intrinsic that actually run as sim D
instructions on sale so for example you
can say SPU underscore mul ad and it's
going to do a vector Malad and so you
can get the kind of assembly language
level control over your code without
having to use any assembly language and
then is that there is a full system
simulator the simulator is very very
accurate for things that do not run out
to main memory they've been working to
improve this so I don't know if recently
they have made it more accurate but if
you're doing compute intensive stuff if
your compute bound you'll be the
simulator can give you accuracies within
99% you know within 1% of the real value
I've only seen one thing on the
simulator more than one 1% off and that
was 4% so the simulator is very good
excuse me very reliable and I I
encourage you to use it if you can't get
access to hardware what else the
simulator has all kinds of tools in
there and I I'm not going to go through
the software stack for the simulation
[Music]
this gives you a sense for what you've
got your hardware running here you can
run this on any one of these platforms
PowerPC Intel or with these OSS you get
the whole thing is written in tickle the
simulator and it has all these kind of
simulators it's simulating the DMAs it's
it's simulating the caches and then you
get a graphical user interface and a
command-line interface to that simulator
the graphical user interface is
convenient but the command line gives
you much more control you can tweak
parameters this gives you a view of what
the what the the graphical user face it
looks like it says Mambo zebra because
that was a different project but now
probably says system sim or something
like that and you'll see the PPC this is
the PPE I don't know why they change it
and then you have SPU 0 SP 1 going down
and it gives you some access to these
parameters the model here it says
pipeline and then there's one another
[Music]
I think functional mode or pipeline mode
pipeline mode is where it's really
simulating everything and much it's much
slower but it's accurate and then the
others functional mode just to test that
your code actually works so it's
supposed to do is since you guys each
group has access to a real Hardware you
can do most of the things in the real
hardware and use the debugger in the
hardware that probably you can talk
about but if things get really bad and
you can't understand you simulate as a
very accurate debugger only in it's
needed because there you can look at
every little detail inside so just this
is kind of a thing one last resort type
thing yeah I agree I come from like I
said I've been doing this for 3 years 3
years ago we didn't even have hardware
right so the simulator was all we had so
we relied on it a lot but I think that
usage of it makes a lot of sense this is
the graphical interface you know it's
just a tickle interface shows you I'm
going to skip through these things it
just shows you how you can look at
memory with this
it's more memory access you get some
graphical representation of various
pieces you know how many stalls how many
loads any DMA transactions so you can
see what's going on at that level and
all of this can be pulled together into
this UART window here okay so the Linux
it's pretty standard Linux but it has
some extensions
let's see provided as a patch yeah that
might be wrong I don't know where we are
currently you have this SPE thread API
for creating threads from the PPEs
let's see what I want to tell you here
there's a better slide for this kind of
information they share the memory space
we talked about that is error event and
signal handling so there are multiple
ways to communicate right you can
communicate with the interrupts in the
event in and signaling that way or you
can use these mailboxes
so each SPE has its own mailbox and
inbox in an outbox so you can post
something to your outbox and then the
PPE will read it when it's ready or you
can read from the inbox waiting on the
PPE to write something now be careful
because you can stall there if the PPE
hasn't written you will stall waiting
for something to fill up so you can do a
check there are things to get a ways to
get around that but these are kind of
common gotchas that you have to watch
out for then you have that you have the
mailboxes you have the interrupts you
also have dmas you can do communication
with DMA so you have at least three
different ways that you can communicate
between the SPE s on sell and which one
is going to be best it really depends on
the algorithm you're running so these
are the extensions to linux it's going
to show you a bunch of things that you
probably won't be able to read but
there's something called SPU FS the
filesystem that has a bunch of open
read/write and closed functionality
right
and then we also have what this
signalling and the mailboxes that I
mentioned to you previously and this you
can't even read I can't even read this
one what is it ah this is perhaps the
most important one it says that SPO
create thread right
so the SPE s from the Linux point of
view are just threads that are running
the the Linux doesn't really know that
their special purpose hardware it just
knows it's a thread and you can do
things like spawn a thread kill a thread
wait on a thread all the usual things
that you can do with threads so it's a
lot like P threads but it's not actually
P threads so here you can see these
things are more useful this is SPE
create groups so you can create a thread
and thread group so that threads that
are part of the same group know about
one another so you can partition your
system and have three SP ease doing one
thing and v doing another so that you
can split up however you like you have
getting set affinity so that you can
choose which SP es are running which
tasks so that you can get more efficient
use of that element interconnect bus
kill and waits open close
writing signals usual okay oops let me
check my time here I really don't have a
lot more time so I'm gonna let you I'm
gonna say that we have we have this
thread management library has the
functionality that I just mentioned in
the next month or so you're gonna go
through that in a lot more detail
the SBE comes with a lot of sample
libraries these are not necessarily the
very best implementation of these
libraries and they're not even fully
functional libraries but they're
suggestive of first of all how things
can be written to sell how to use sell
and then in some cases how to optimize
sell like the basic matrix operations
there's some optimization the FFTs are
very tightly optimized so if you want to
take a look at that and understand how
to do that type of memory manipulation
so there's their sample codes out there
that can be very useful
just keep that oh this is that FFT
16-million does an example it sits on
the sdk actually I don't know if you've
got ps3s if all these things gonna run
you should they should run yeah they
should run there may be some memory
issues out the main memory that I'm not
aware of there are all kinds of demos
there that you can play with which
you're good for learning how to sponsor
and some things like that you have your
basic good new Bing utils tools there's
GCC out there there's also excel C you
can download excel see in some cases one
will be better than the other but I
think in most cases Excel sees a little
better or in some cases it's actually a
lot better so you can get that and I
recommend that there's a debugger which
provides application source level
debugging PPE multi-threading SP
multi-threading the interactions between
these guys there are three modes for the
debugger the standalone and then
attached to SP threads that sounds like
tootin it hmm that's problematic there's
this nice static analysis tool this is
good for looking for really tightly
optimizing your code you have to be able
to read assembly but it shows you
graphically kind of where the stalls are
happening and you can try and reorganize
your code and then like someone
suggested the the dynamic analysis using
the simulator is a good way to really
get
cycle by cycle stepping through the code
and this someone was very excited when
they made this chart because they put
these big explosions here you've you've
got some you've got some compiler here
that's gonna be generating two pieces of
code the PPE binary and the SPE binary
when you go through the the SEL
tutorials for training on how to program
cell you'll see that this code is
actually plugged into linked into the
PPE code and when the PPE code spawns a
thread it's going to take a pointer to
this code and basically DMA that code
into the SPE until the SPE to start
running once it's done that that thread
is independent it the the PPE could kill
it but it could just let it run to its
natural termination or this thing could
terminate itself or it could be
interrupted by some other communication
but that's a basic process you have
these two pieces of code okay so now
this is really what I wanted to get to
and I think I want lots of questions
here and there are four levels of
parallelism in cell on the cell blade
the IBM blade you have two cell
processors per blade so that's one level
of parallelism the chip level we know
there are nine cores and they're all
running independently that's another
level of parallelism on the instruction
level each of the SPE s has two
instruction pipelines so it's an odd and
an even pipeline one pipeline is doing
things the odd pipeline is doing loads
and stores DMA transactions interrupts
branches and it's doing something called
shuffle byte or the shuffle operation so
a shuffle operation is very very useful
operation that allows you to take those
sixteen take two registers as data a
third register as a pattern register and
a fourth register as output it then from
this pattern will choose arbitrarily the
bytes that are in these two and
reconstitute them into this fourth
register it's wonderful for doing
manipulations and shuffling things
around
it's like shuffling a deck
you can get basically you could take all
of these and ignore this or you could
take the first one here replicate it 16
times or you could take a random
sampling from these put it into that
register we do use it yeah yeah you take
a look you'll see we use shuffle a lot
it's surprising how valuable shuffle can
be however then you have to worry now
you've got the shuffle here if you're
doing like a matrix transpose it's all
shuffles but what's a date matrix
transpose it's really bandwidth bound
right because you're pulling data in
shuffling it around and sending it up
well where the read and writes they're
on the odd pipeline where are the
shuffles they're on the odd pipeline so
now you can have a situation where it's
all shuffle shuffle shuffle shuffle
shuffle and then the instruction
prefetch buffer gets starved and so it
stalls for 1517 cycles while it has to
load basically it's a tiny little loop
right it's but you get stalls and get a
really bad performance so then you have
to tell the compiler but actually the
compiler is much getting better at these
things much better than it used to be or
by hand you can force it to leave a slot
for the prefetch leaves of gotchas and
you know programmers have to be aware of
ok so then on the other pipeline you
have all your normal operations right so
you have your
mul ads your bid operations all the
shifts and things like that they're all
over there
there is one other operation on the odd
pipeline and I think it's a quadword
rotate or something but I don't remember
so that's instruction level dual issue
parallelism and then everything is in
order on this processor yeah should and
that was done for power can reasons
right get rid of all the space and all
the transistors that are doing all this
fancy out of order processing to save
power
that's a really good point when you're
doing scalar processing right you think
well you're thinking I'm gonna kind of
conceptually you want to have all the
things that are doing the same thing
together right well that's how I used to
program it right you you put all this
stuff here then you do maybe all your
reads or whatever and then you do all
your computes and then you can't do it
that way you have to really think about
how you're going to interleave these
things now the compiler will help you
but to get really high performance you
have to have better tools and we don't
have those tools yet and so I'm hoping
that you guys are the ones that are
going to come up with the new tools and
new ideas that are gonna really help
people improve program ability of self
all right and then at the the lowest
level you have these the register level
parallelism where you can have you know
4 float single precision floating
simultaneously so when your program
Excel you have to keep all of these
levels of hierarchy in your head it's
not straight scale or programming
anymore and if you think of it that way
you're just not going to get the
performance that you're looking for
period another consideration is this
local store right each local stores is
20 to 256 kilobytes that's not a lot of
space right you have to think about how
are you going to bring the data in so
that the chunks are big enough but not
too big because if they're too big then
you won't be able to get multi buffering
right so if your data chunk is well
let's back up a little bit more the
local store holds the data but it also
holds holds the code that you're running
so if you have 200 kilobytes of code
then you only have 56 kilobytes of data
space and if you want to have double
buffering that means you only have
25 kilobytes and then as-salam correctly
points out there's the problem of stack
right so if you're gonna have recursion
in your code or something nasty like
that you can start putting pushing stack
variables off the register file so where
do they go they go in the local store
what's prevents the logo of the stack
from overriding your data nothing
nothing at all
and that's a big gotcha I've seen over
the past three years maybe 30 separate
algorithms implemented on sale and I
know of only one that was definitely
doing that but you know if there are 30
people in this class maybe you're gonna
be the one that that happens to so you
have to be aware of that and you have to
deal with so what you can do is in the
local store put you know some dead beef
thing in there so that you can look for
and overwrite and that will let you know
that either you have to make your code
smaller or your data smaller or get rid
of recursion on SP ease recursion is
kind of anathema inlining is good
inlining is really can accelerate your
codes performance oh yeah that's it says
stack right there right you're reading
ahead on me yeah yeah so all three are
in there and that's you have to be aware
of that now there is a memory management
library very lightweight library on the
SPE and it's going to prevent your data
from overwriting your code because once
the codes loaded that memory management
library knows where it is and it will
stop the date you from allocating do
animalic over this code but the stack
it's up for grabs and that was again
done because of power considerations and
real estate on the chip you if you want
to have a chip that's you know you know
this big you can have anything you want
but it's it you know manufacturing it's
impossible so things were removed and
that was one of the things that's
removed and that's one of the things you
have to watch out for and communication
we've talked about this quite a bit I
guess that I didn't mention this the DMA
transactions Oh
question in the back at all conceivable
to have thumps that fetching new code if
you call or an alligator that shuffles
somehow or is it basically as soon as
you get at that point before the spell
yeah well if you don't do anything about
it yes your performance will go to hell
so there are two ways in research we
came up with a an overlay mechanism so
this is what people used to do 20 years
ago right when processors were simple
well these processors are simple right
so going back to the old technologies is
actually a good thing to do so we had a
video processing algorithm where we took
video images we had to decode them with
one SPE we had to do some background
subtraction with the next SPE we had to
do some edge detection and so each SPE
was doing a different thing but even
then the code was very big the chunks of
code were large and we were spending 27
percent of the time swapping code out
and bringing in new code bad very bad
oh and I should tell you spawning SPE
threads is very painful I mean it's it
can 500,000 cycles a million cycles I
don't know it varies depending on how
the SPE feels that particular day and
it's it's something to avoid you really
want to spawn a thread and keep it
running for a long time so context
switching is painful on cell using an
overlay we got that 27% overhead down to
1% so yes you can do that that tool is
not in the SDK it's on my to-do list to
put it in the SDK but the compiler team
at IBM tells me that the xlc compiler
now does overlays but it only does
overlays at the function level so if the
function still doesn't fit in the SPE
you're dead in the water and I think the
compiler will say when it compiles it
it'll say this doesn't fit quietly and
you'll never see that until you run and
it doesn't load and you don't know
what's going on so read your compiler
outputs write the DMA grand
128 bytes this is the same the data
transactions for Intel for AMD they're
all 128 byte data envelopes so if you're
doing a memory access that's four bytes
you're still using a hundred 28 bytes of
bandwidth so this comes back to this
notion of getting a shopping list you
really want to think of ahead what you
want to get bring it in but then use it
so that you don't waste bandwidth if
your bandwidth bound if you're not then
you can be a little more wasteful but um
there's a guy Mike Acton you can find
his website I think he has a website
called um WWL performance dot org Netcom
i don't know oh he's good he's very he's
much better than me you're gonna be
really gonna like him his his belief and
I believe him wholeheartedly is it's all
about the data we're coming to a point
in computer science where the the code
doesn't matter as much as getting the
data where you need it right this is
this is because of the latency out to
main memory it's getting further
memories getting so far away that having
all these cycles you know not that
useful anymore and if you can't get the
data so he always pushes this point
you'd have to get the data you have to
think about the data yeah good code
starts with the data good code ends of
the data good data structures start with
the data you have to think day to day
the data and I can't emphasize that
enough because it's really very very
true
for this processor and I believe for all
the multi-core processors you're gonna
be seeing the DMA is that you you issue
can be 128 128 bytes or multiples of a
hundred twenty bytes up to 16 kilobytes
for a single DMA there's also something
called a DMA list which is a list of
DMAs
in local store and you tell the DMA
queue ok here these hundred DMAs spawn
them off that only takes one slot in
that DMA queue so it's an efficient way
of of loading the queue without
overloading the cube traffic control
just this is perhaps
one of the trickier things with cell
because the simulator doesn't help very
much and the tools don't help very much
thinking about synchronization DMA
latency handling all those things are
important and now yes okay so this is
the last slide that I'm going to do and
then I have to run off I want to give
you a sense for the process by which
people my group in particular went
through especially when we didn't even
have hardware and we didn't have
compilers that work nearly as well as
they do now and it's really very ugly
you know knives and stones six things
you know is this kind of what's it's a
stone knife so that's what I'm thinking
a very primitive but this way of
thinking is still very much true you
have to think about your code this way
you want to start you have your
application whatever it happens to be
you wanna do an algorithmic complexity
study is this order N squared is this
log n what where the bottlenecks what do
I expect to be bottlenecks then I want
to do data layout locality now this is
the data data data approach of Mike
Acton you want to think about the data
where is it how can you structure your
data so that it's going to be
efficiently positioned for when you need
it and then you start with an
experimental partitioning of the
algorithm you want to break it up
between the pieces that you believe are
going to our scaler and remain scalar
leave those on the SPE and the ones that
can be parallelized those are the ones
that are going to go on the SPE so you
can you have to think conceptually about
partitioning that out and then run it on
the PPE anyway right you want to have a
baseline there then you have this this
PPE scalar code and PPE control code
this pped scalar code you want and then
push down to the SPE s so now you're
going to add stuff for communication
synchronization and latency handling so
you have to spawn threads the rights
have to be told where the data is they
have to get their code they have to run
their code they have to then start
pulling in the data synchronized with
the other SPE s and then latency
handling with multi buffering of the
data so that you can be doing
computing and reading data
simultaneously then you have your first
parallel code that's running there now
the compiler the xlc compiler GCC
compiler
well the xlc compiler I know for certain
we'll do some automatic simdization if
you put the auto CMD flag on does GCC
compiler do that yeah
good exactly yeah okay so I don't know
if the GCC compiler does that so that
can be done by hand but you know
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't and it really depends on how
complex the algorithm if it's a very
regular code like a matrix matrix
multiply you'll see that the compiler
can do fairly well if if it if the block
sizes are right and all but if you have
something that's more irregular then you
may find that doing it by hand is really
required and so this step here could be
done with the compiler initially to see
if you're getting the performance that
you think you should be getting from
that algorithmic complexity study right
so you should see that type of scaling
you should look you can look at the CPI
and see how many cycles per instruction
you're getting right each SPE should be
getting 0.5 right you should be able to
get two instructions per cycle
very few codes actually get exactly okay
you know you can get down to 5.8 or
something like that but I think if you
can get to one you're doing well if you
get to two there's probably more you can
be doing and if you're above two there's
something wrong with your code it may be
the algorithm it may be it's just a poor
poorly chosen algorithm that that's
where you can talk to me right I want to
make myself available to everyone in the
class or in my department as well I uh
we're very enthusiastic about working
with research groups and universities to
develop new tools new new methods and
and if you can help me I can help you
that I think it works very well then
once you've done this you may find that
what you originally thought for the
complexity or the layout
wasn't quite accurate so you need to
then go do some additional rebalancing
maybe change your block sizes that you
you know maybe you had 64 by 64 blocks
now you need 32 by 64 or 48 bytes
whatever some readjustment to match what
you have and then you may want to
re-evaluate the data movement and then
you know in many cases you'll be done
but you're looking at your cycles per
instruction or your speed-up and you're
not seeing exactly what you expected so
you can start looking at other
optimization considerations like using
the vector unit the vmx unit on the Cell
processor on the PPE looking for system
bottlenecks and this is actually I have
found the biggest problem right trying
to identify where the DMA bottlenecks
are happening is kind of devilishly hard
we don't have good tools for that and so
you really have to think hard and come
up with interesting kind of experiments
for your code to track down these
bottlenecks and then load balancing if
you look at these SPE s I told you
they're completely independent you can
have them all running the same code or
they could be running all different code
they can be daisy chained so that this
one feeds this one feeds that one feeds
that one if you do that daisy chaining
you may find out there's a bottleneck
that this SPE takes you know three times
as long as any of the others so make
that use three SPE s and have this SPE
feed these three and you know so you
have to do some load balancing and
thinking about how many SPE s really
need to be dedicated to each of the
tasks now that's that's the end of my
talk I think that gives you a good sense
of where we where we have been where we
are now and where we're going and I hope
that it was good educational and I'll
make myself available to you guys in the
future and if you have any questions
that I think you take you
plate how much time we have for
questions not much I'm supposed to leave
it 110
so I supposed to be you should be there
by 12 okay so we said I see at some time
my car is out in the okay okay so we
will have about five minutes
questions okay so I know this talk is
early and we haven't gotten a lot of
basics so there might be a lot of things
kind of going above your head but what
will slowly get back to it so questions
not that I'm aware of
we did look at something called micro
MPI where we were using kind of a very
watered-down MPI lay implementation for
the SPS and transactions I don't
recommend it what I recommend is you
have a cluster saying you know a
thousand node cluster and the code today
the legacy code that's out there runs
some process on on this node take that
process don't try to push MPI further
down but just try to sub partition that
process and have the SPS community let
the it let the PPE handle all the
communication off off board off node
that's that's my recommendation yeah
openmpi there's an open source MPI it's
just a recompile and it hasn't been
tuned or optimized but it and it doesn't
know anything about the SPE s so then
you just you know you let the PPE do all
the communication or handle the
communications when it finishes the task
at hand then it can do issue its MPI
process
openmp is the methodology where you take
existing scalar code and you insert
compiler pragmas to say this for loop
can be parallelized and you know this
data structures are disjoint so we don't
have to worry about any kind of
interference you know side-effects of
the data manipulation the compiler the
xlc compiler implements OpenMP there are
several components that are required one
was a software cache where they
implement a like a little cash on the
local store and if if it misses in that
local cache it goes and gets it I don't
know how well that performs yet but it
exists there's the simdization for a
while openmp wasn't working with auto
simdization but now it does so it's
getting there for C it's there I don't
know what type of performance you hit
you take for that it's Excel C version
does that mean I don't know if she does
it but my recommendation is if you want
to use openmp go ahead take your scalar
code implement it with those
instructions with those fragments see
what help of improvement you can play
around with the little and if you find
something that you expect should be 10x
better and it's only 3x take that
bottleneck and implement it by hand I
suspect and most of these answers come
down to the same thing it comes back to
Sony Sony contract with IBM gave us a
lot of money to make this thing and they
said we need it for the PlayStation 3 we
need this this this this and so IBM was
very focused on providing those things
now that that is delivered PlayStation 3
is being sold we're looking at other
options and you know that if that's
something that you're interested in
pursuing talk to me
I think yeah that this is very new area
so you have to have before you put
things in hardware you do have some kind
of consensus what's the right way to do
it so what this is it's a bare metal
that gives you huge amount of
opportunity but you give enough rope to
hang yourself and and the key thing is
you can get all this performance and
what will happen perhaps in next few
years as people come up to consensus
saying look everybody has to do this
everybody needs MP I need this cash and
slowly some of those features feel a
little bit of a feature creep so you are
going to have little bit of over here a
little bit less power efficient but it
will much easier program but this is
kind of the bare metal thing that you
get and it's in some sense it's a nice
time because I think in five years if
you look at a cell you don't you won't
have this level of access you will have
all this nice niceties built on top of
an end doing this so this is a unique
position in there it's very hard to deal
with but also on the other hand you get
to see underneath you get to see all
without any kind of these other things
it layer so my feeling is in few years
you'll get all those things put back
when if if you figure out how to deal
with things like segmentation on a
multi-core with a very fine-grained
communication and there's a lot of
issues in that you need to figure out
right right now all those issues exposed
it's like okay you don't know how to do
it
okay you go figure it out okay thank you
thank you that much more material so I
have about probably 10 15 minutes do you
guys need a break or should we just go
directly to the end how many people see
you on the break